this morning there is panic in parts of
the Philippines after the eruption of a
volcano about 40 miles south of the
capital city of Manila nearly half a
million people are in harm's way there
more than 16,000 in the immediate area
have already been evacuated and more
eruptions could be imminent dramatic
video shows a lightning storm yesterday
in the volcanic clouds a skewed in the
air for miles Howard Johnson from our
partners at the BBC air near the volcano
and took a tie where ash has blanketed
nearby villages all volcano has now
entered a magmatic eruptions last night
it was a phreatic phase where there was
lots of steam and ash now there is lava
flowing from the volcano a weak flow at
the moment but that's causing this black
smoke to billow out of the volcano now
if we look to my left here you can see
ash all over the floor it's turned into
a mud State in some places and on the
road on the way up here we saw people
clearing that mud from the road we also
saw pineapple groves completely covered
in the dust and that's no doubt can
affect livelihoods in this area now the
other major risk that the scientists are
saying is that there could be a volcanic
tsunami if now if there is a major
eruption that could cause cause the
earth to move which will displace water
and so low-lying communities on the
coastline here could be affected by a
tidal wave if there is a major eruption
you